right thank so much for coming everyone
my name is Ian Cooper and today what I'd
like to talk to you about is creating a
renaissance around dotnet development
some of you may have seen me speak
before the only interesting point and
that whole BIOS the one on the bottom
and that's that I'm not no understanding
here is smarter than you right just we
have had the confidence to get up and
talk you are just as smart as us I
promise you and please feel encouraged
to do what I do here and get yourself in
speak at events and conferences the more
the greater the range of voices we have
the better so where I work I don't care
about that apart from the fact that it's
I have nothing to sell you we're not a
consultancy we ship software ok I'm
going to talk today about where I think
we are and in dotnet land where I think
the sake of players I think we're in a
bit of a decline I want to talk about
why I think there's a bit of a decline
and I want to talk about how I think we
can have a renaissance that gets us out
of that particular decline and
reinvigorates both the platform and the
community I very grateful if people
would take this to a discussion on
social media we had some of you imagine
I did a blog post a while back about
some of these ideas and some of the
problems that we're facing and I think
this is something I'd like to see the
community engage with more widely so
anyone wants to tweet I might keep it by
the way that's my twitter handle but I'd
be very grateful anyone's a tweet at all
during this picture presentation about
ideas they find interesting and if you
disagree you might really disagree with
what I'm saying and that's all part of
the debate I want to kick start a debate
rather than necessarily say I am right
ok so what is I don't know Renaissance
what one might one might we need one ok
this guy here is basically Bob Lee and
in 2011 OS con he said we are on the
cusp of a Java Renaissance and what he
was basically the CTR Square at a time
and he was alluding to the fact that
there have been a significant fall and
the number of people using the JVM to
build tikki website
and the reason was rails rail to come
along and was an exceptionally
productive environment people to work
with and as a result people just stopped
using the JVM to do it at a time
remember the JVM is enterprise javabeans
that kind of thing it's not really a
productive environment and Bob's point
was though that there have been a number
of changes people have begun to work on
new ideas Nettie's one of the ones calls
out and at the same time people were
beginning to find the Twitter story is
quite famous get Twitter fire wails the
rails wasn't scaling for them and so
there's a return to the JVM as a
platform that could meet the scaling
needs of these successful sites and he
called this the Java Renaissance and I'd
like to argue that we are in a similar
position today that we are seeing a
decline and these particularly over
speed on that and that we need to look
for what will give us a similar
renaissance in dotnet today I will talk
a lot in when I talk about the evidence
for this about c-sharp and the reason
simply as mads points out is that we are
several orders of magnitude greater and
a number of developers on that platform
equally though when we talk about the
future the platform you know a rising
tide lifts all boats so we are obviously
involving ourselves in raising Visual
Basic and F sharp at the same time okay
so this is some data from indeed calm to
the US job site and what it's showing
here is the other slide that's
interesting okay maybe this but this is
showing basically the difference between
Python and c-sharp job postings in the
u.s. between 2012 and 2016 and you can
see that the orange line which is
basically C sharp declines from about
1.4 to about nine point eight nine
percent it's not quite a 50% reduction
in jobs in the US but it is of that
order and you might say oh well maybe
they're just the less computing jobs you
know recession neck cutting cetera but
if you see Python at the same period of
time it's growing from about not 0.5
after just over basically one and then
factually now
this is indicating that there are more
Python vacancies in the US than there
are essentially c-sharp vacancies so
there's a pattern to kind that the US
job data is indicating to us
this is UK job data and the UK is very
interesting because by a significant
number of measures c-sharp is more
popular in the UK than Java and has been
for some time and that's primarily
probably due to the influence of the
finance sector and languages are
regional you know you're fine C sharp
Center clusters in Seattle lost in
London places like that that's right so
it's a good bellwether right and you can
see here that effectively although that
the permanent jobs have bubbled between
somewhere around
Piku thirty five percent in 2013 they'd
fallen by about five percent in a minute
over the last four or five years or so
from that peak and contract jobs have
been declining slightly earlier they'd
fallen from about 25 to about 18 percent
so a slightly bigger decline double of
course of c-sharp and talking about
c-sharp jobs is you know c-sharp
includes both at a desktop environment
where Windows is still prevalent where
there are not really many contenders
against things like WPF for writing
essentially your your code so it's more
interesting intention to talk about
areas where there's greater competition
and that be on the server so we can look
at numbers for asp.net you look at the
numbers for asp.net you can see that the
top line which is permanent jobs again
peaked around 2012 around 27% in UK
development jobs sensory c-sharp but
it's now at about 23 so the client of
four or five three or four percent there
but what's particularly interesting to
me is the bottom line which is contract
jobs there's a huge crash around the
time the financial crash in terms of
those jobs but what's interesting is
they never recovered they never came
back to C sharp since about 2012 we
fallen from about 15% to something like
9% and this matches a lot with my
anecdotal understanding of the jobs
market in the UK though I'm not a
contractor lots of people I know are a
speed up net contractors and they say
they are finding increasingly difficult
to find decent air speed internet
contracts most of them are really
maintenance work they're not seeing new
projects and that's a very kind of
interesting proposition because
in the UK certainly there is an overall
pattern which is many enterprises hire
contractors when they are building new
projects to help get up to speed and
tend to use permanent style for business
as usual given that we know there must
be due to the peak of C sharp in the UK
a huge number or he might have existing
code out there that's going to have to
be maintained for years we would expect
to see the early signs of decline in the
contract market where we see new
projects taking off I'd argue that
there's reasonable evidence that we've
been in decline as a particular server
side platform since about 2012 and
certainly our joint huddle I think about
2011 2012 and at the time there was a
cluster of UK's felt ups under much less
Bismarck program all using C sharp asked
just eat just giving and a few other
platforms around that essentially were
quite popular a few payday loan banks
like longer etc and there's a real
splurge of activity but more recently I
don't see the same number of startups
actually engaging with a speed-up net as
a natural platform to be using when they
come out the gate so overall this is
kind of what's happening while we
declining like this okay I think one of
the first questions we ought to ask is
if people have left the platform where
have they gone because by understanding
where they've gone we may be able to
understand what the threats are to the
platform and how we actually fix that
problem this is from the stack overflow
developer hiring landscape information
you can download see the global numbers
there are more specific country ones
butting the global ones tell the story
well enough so if you look on the on the
left hand side you'll see essentially
languages people are effectively working
in I've drawn a line about 10% so it's a
language that have more than 10% market
share and they'll be the ones you kind
of expect right C sharp Python Java PHP
a sequin and JavaScript and then down
below some ones that effectively are
contending to that space and the
most-wanted language is the things
developers want to work in the big
additions are things like go typescript
swift and Ruby right those are the
languages that developers say
there are less jobs essentially than
they want there to be in so they're
definitely a movement there in terms of
direction this is from O'Reilly and this
is their web developer survey and this
kind of shows you what technologies are
being used by web developers today and
you can see that espy don't net about 70
percent c-sharp is 2 percent I imagine
what that is is people working in things
like Nancy as a separate line item or
just confusion when they're filling in
the form but if you add those two
together see that's about 90% it's
behind Python and Java
it's way behind brings that PHP and
setting behind you out the script ok so
look at some of the languages and see
what's happened to them in recent years
so this is JavaScript jobs in the UK
most of us are aware of the inexorable
climb of JavaScript but there is some
evidence for you essentially really Java
ships you know takes off somewhere
around 2010 2011 and has been climbing
ever since you may say well that's just
front-end jobs people doing angular in
it doesn't really affect guys doing a
speed-up net but this is basically again
from Stack Overflow and that indicates
basically the back end developers are
now listening Java Script is basically a
primary tool that they're using ok you
can see c-sharp position by comparison
it's a global number so that's why
slightly different from say the UK
numbers you seen earlier even if we
change this graph and say let's just
focus on job adverts explicitly
mentioned nodejs on the back end you can
see that from about 2012 the same period
we've identified as being the point of
which we begin to see a decline in the
dot in the air speed up net market
nodejs
takes off and now climbs to something
like around 9% of jobs and is
essentially you can roughly equate the
loss in asp.net jobs to the rise in
node.js jobs obviously the market may be
growing or expanding so you know some of
those jobs could be entirely new jobs
etc ok when you look at say Stack
Overflow again and you look at what the
most popular technologies in 2013 know
jess is towards the bottom this list has
a small number and angular is almost
non-existent
separated out from actually from
JavaScript itself and see charts about
40 you can 2016 and you can see their no
Jess has climbed dramatically and as
angular and c-sharp is amongst the
fallers so I think there's a pretty
clear sort of evidence that no GS is
essentially dominating the server
platform of server platform space and we
have lost market share and developer
interest to that platform interesting
enough this is Ryan who knows who Ryan
is by the way yeah so Ryan forgot the
cratered no Jess interesting up on
LinkedIn only 21 people think Ryan's any
good and no Jess which kind of
demonstrates the value of LinkedIn as a
hiring platform okay
Java the people in Java interesting Java
is suffering similar to us right so
although Java starts globally like well
in the u.s. essentially the high-water
mark about through it but it's just
under 3 percent of US jobs and the trend
line is very similar you know this is a
big similar established language and
it's falling you can look at a good
question whether it includes Android
talk about the next slide so John was
asking these androids this shows UK jobs
and you can see that 2009 looks a little
bit normal s to me but that's the period
Bob was talking about when everyone left
JVM for rails you can see some recovery
in 2000 and so it could be a renaissance
and you can see recent is an uptick the
the question about the up to here is is
John raises whether or not that's
Android and that's quite likely that
that androids at least reinvigorated
Java nor in a reasonable way that we
haven't necessarily had and the c-sharp
platform Python but there's also climbed
considerably Ida Python now as well as
c-sharp
so maybe I'm a bellwether of that
particular experience and yeah you can
see that it's bubbling around 2012 but
place went about this huge climb in
Python development you can see that even
on Stack Overflow questions this class
can be a little bit hard to read but the
two lines trending up the green and the
orange lines are essentially JavaScript
and Python the ones trending down are C
sharp and Java
so there's a growth in both those
languages basically on stackoverflow
more people asking questions in other
words or people learning and trying to
understand how to use those toolkits
buttons interesting because it you know
it's difficult to know whether it's a
direct challenge or essentially to
something like a speed-up net via django
is that direct challenger because a lot
of the growth in Python could be about
the fact that Python dominates people
doing effectively math because
especially has huge libraries for doing
scientific computation and dealing with
data and for many people that grow the
data science machine learning has been a
growth in interest in Python PHP I must
say about PHP you know emerged about
2010's remain pretty stable ever since
PHP has it's sweet spore loads develop
for Facebook but in addition are things
like Magento were so e-commerce
platforms it looks kind of hard to shift
its bubbling along I don't think people
left a spur net to go to PHP I think the
two are just essentially alongside each
other okay what the also-rans around
here scholar and ruby they're both about
6% I have a lot of anecdotal people
saying to me how everyone's going to do
Scala
right and Scala really benefited from
job as long painful teatime of the soul
between Java 7 and Java right
Scala I was with doing something and
therefore there was interest in Scala
would you whether Java rate has stemmed
that a little bit I don't know but there
are also emergent players and JVM like
Kotlin it's an interesting one but
scholar was one of those languages were
I know quite people who are interested
in functional programming working
scholar because it's functional
programming but heat scholar as the
worst example of functional programming
so I think that very conflicted
development community and Twitter
flirted with skull and then abandoned it
so skull as one of those ones I don't
know whether it'll really climb out of
its position
Ruby again Ruby's actually go
interesting in the UK this number is
actually quite it takes off quite late
and climbs quite slowly in the US this
number actually got you know Ruby takes
off a lot earlier and I rose as an
interesting one people talk about rails
now suffering from the monocot Ruby
suffered the monocultural rails of DHH
and questioning whether or not you know
it's in a position that was criticized
in the.net platform years ago as
being you know very monocultural the
question used to be Ruby or Python who's
winning and the answer really pretty
clearly is Piketon okay what about the
others well there's kind of a long tail
of things that are kind of emergent
languages that the smart kids tell you
about that they're playing with so you
know Uncle Bob and Eric Evans are always
playing with closure and some of the
smart kids in the.net platform you know
mark seem and people are always playing
with f-sharp and they're telling us how
exciting and wonderful these languages
are but they don't capture a huge
proportion of the job market today right
you know these numbers essentially are
below 1% the UK job market by comparison
to like you know even in decline C
sharps in 10 20 % regions so their
orders a magnitude below so they are
there people love them but they're not
really dominant players in the
marketplace it's not as C sharp with the
client because everyone's now an F sharp
developer certain go certain go
accelerated rapidly and are doing in a
sense much better at escaping this
adoption curve than F sharp and closure
are Swift obviously because who wants to
use Objective C and go goes very
interesting go is really climbed and I
think you know someone that can be
explained the interesting things like
docker console or terraform those kind
of language is written and go but the
rest of it is it's very accessible for
developers from a sea background Java C
sharp to go to its performance fast it's
a nice sweet spot and definitely all the
graphs you see will point to go as being
something that you should pay attention
to as coming up as a language so in
conclusion where'd everyone go I think
the big contender is no Jess in terms of
server-side losses I think you know
there's a small amount of drift out to
Python but I wonder whether actually
people are doing Python as well as doing
other languages and there's a smaller
drift out even smaller to drift out to
scholar and so rails but the big thing
is no Jess came along and it captured a
huge amount of the server market okay so
it's a white-wine environment in the
position we in I mean why didn't things
like no Jess take off I think one of the
key problem is that our platform has
traditionally had
is essentially Linux I'll show you a
bigger version this this number these
some numbers essentially out of
Wikipedia is difficult to get consistent
numbers but the headline is this 2/3 of
servers basically are Linux and 1/3 of
servers are Windows traditionally the
model works a bit like this for Windows
Windows used to really have a sweet spot
in small and medium-sized businesses so
your your a company up to about 200
employees have a kind of data center on
premise and the people that look after
that data center are Windows people and
they look after the desktops and they
look after the service and they look
after exchange and they look after the
software that's been installed by the
third party company inside that
something goes wrong and that model wall
is the dominant model for a long period
of time and it created a lot of Windows
servers which meant Windows is a great
platform to deploy to if you were
targeting small medium sized businesses
what happens was we've begun to shift
towards SAS model software as a service
so you're running somewhere in a data
center in a Colo or on the cloud and
those businesses are dropping data
centers away and actually just having
desktops and even exchange is now moving
to the cloud and that is essentially
hammering into Windows because in the
big data centers and the colors what you
really care about a scale is ability to
automate you know the fact you can SH H
into basically a machine and deal with
it you can write scripting and that has
the lead and sense to the resurgence of
Linux basically on those platforms and
Linux has things like container
technologies etc and Windows is
constantly trying to play catch-up in
those particular environments because it
was built for a different kind of
scenario it was built to be very similar
to the desktop to have an ease of use
for the guy and you basically work for
the SMB that ran your exchange supported
your office installs your local desktops
as well as the service and not running
on Linux makes life difficult for doing
that obviously that's been fixed by job
net call the other real kind of threat
that we have is that the OSS ecosystem
in dotnet for some time has been
continually criticized as lacking so
this is our scholar I always wanted to
build a distributed system in net
and he had to write most of it himself
and his experiment he's the guy behind
one of the guys when a kid on that and
his experience was that he couldn't find
the building blocks he needed lots of
projects in OSS there were ideas people
had had but they were all very
unfinished because they didn't have much
take up our involvement or they were
just simply kind of Ithaca saan code
project and then by comparison to say
the Java ecosystem he was he struggled
continually to find the kind of tools he
needed so he had to go and write for
example libraries to talk to Cassandra
he had to write a high-performance
tcp/ip stack of given to Nettie
there was no actor framework so he had
to go and write a cornet write all these
things are problems that he was
encountering and that kind of burden
means it's just easy to go and use
something else right one of the classic
problems here a little bit is is this
notion our OSS community has been a
little bit weakened by the presence of
Microsoft so what happens is this
traditional model you know someone goes
away Charlie Poole and James Newkirk
create an unit it wins awards
essentially is a piece of code but
Microsoft replaced with MS test some
people pour hibernate people like it in
they work very hard and hibernate it's
potentially you know an overpowered ORM
for most people as uses but it's very
powerful and it has I you know had
strong ideas atomic persistence
ignorance inside it myself chooses
entity framework because the original
version has this weird double
abstraction model out of 1970s but
attentively crushes in hibernate Hammett
works on monorail which essentially is
NVC framework effectively for dotnet
environment inspired by rails it's
pretty successful and then as Peter MVC
comes out and crushes it and this was a
model which led to people being very
unenthusiastic about writing LSS in.net
because there's a feeling that if your
project took off and became successful
Microsoft would simply just write their
own version and release it and your
project because it then can essentially
drowned by the 500-pounder under in them
every developer looks at what Microsoft
is doing reads it it's very hard to get
your project noticed in the LSS space if
you're not like
so right you know I work on access
protocol brighter if people who use it
but it's very hard for us to basically
get traction globally right you know
unless I go to all the US conferences
and speak about it it's hard to SAP your
struggle as it is it doesn't help when
Microsoft effectively crushes that
innovation okay it's a language itself
right here's a question is it C sharp I
don't think so a C sharps on them on the
most loved list it's not there were
things like F sharp and other languages
basically the developers are really
saying these are the hot hot tools rust
and go both side top 10 language long
side things that Python and nodejs wrote
which it beats I don't think people are
leaving the platform because I don't
like c-sharp is it because everyone's
we've the functional languages right all
the smart kids do functional languages
the rest of us wander around going I
feel stupid but the reality is as we saw
earlier from those graphs that the
numbers of positions in functional
languages don't suggest that we are
seeing a move away from platforms
because they're not functional and the
rise of go which is not relative
functional languages a language
demonstrates that there are still a
significant appetite for our languages
this is Roger again talking essentially
on Twitter recently about the fact that
stack overflows numbers suggest that you
know we are way past the peak people
asking questions about F sharp on Stack
Overflow talk a little bit about how
language you can adoption in a second so
I think the thing to understand is that
you know if you're I see occasional an
issue from people saying oh you know C
sharps in the client people are
interested in it but F sharp that's
where the future is that shop is not
your reserve parachute on the platform
in order to save the platform we have to
save c-sharp you're not going to be able
to say that by basically pulling the F
shop reserve parachute rip cord right is
it because it's a static language so
dynamic language I find so really
interesting because this is my career I
thought of as a foxpro developer which
is basically a dynamic language very
powerful tool we had things like inline
sequel etc long before effectively they
emerged where things that link but we
found it as a number of problems is a
weekly tight dynamic language and you
could do interests
things like completely changing the type
of a value halfway through a loop etc
and the bugs and that used to drive us
all crazy so so so so crush to where we
by dynamic languages and the bugs that
occur with them we went all the way to
C++ because we thought types we love
them we want as much of them as we can
possibly have
C++ proved unproductive so I went to C
sharp and then nowadays add a bit of
Python as well though admittedly I'd
quite often use pep for it for is
optional typing okay and I have an
opinion like this which says generally I
think the thing is cyclical what happens
is is that we start effectively while
using our lovely static language it's
all computer science e or controlling
types are building our domain model our
compiler is giving a tons of information
then someone goes but it's so slow I'm
watching all my di Oh Milo sea
containers my factories of factories all
these interfaces I just want duck typing
right would be so much easier be so much
faster so they pick up Python or they
pick up Ruby I need a vamp dynamic
language and it goes great they're
really fast and then their site explodes
in size and their protein have more
people on board and it's finding it's
quite hard sometimes to figure out what
the hell is the parameter and that is
basically in this function signature is
supposed to be I have to essentially you
know spelunk the code by working through
it to find out what methods are called
duck typing is great but it'd be nice to
know kind of what you want the duck to
do in some fashion right and so
knowledge enough code bases it turns to
be out to be really hard with a dynamic
language to actually maintain it so then
everyone says well we're getting a
static language again next time right
and this cycle goes round and I think
actually the cycle is even more
complicated than that is that sometimes
when we use a static language we say you
know this problem was still too hard to
get under control with static languages
it's still too complex it's so I want to
be declarative I'm going to write a DSL
right with the old old-school way of
doing this on nowadays I'm going to move
to a functional language with a strong
type system like Haskell or F sharp and
then we get the problem that half my
developers go I don't understand what's
actually going on and this DSL is hiding
too much from me wow this functional
declaration right any better damming so
I think it's just a cyclical thing of
none of these things are Silver Bullet
and everyone just just gravitating one
on the other depending upon what are the
problem space they had last time
so I don't believe that being a sapphic
language per se is a problem for C shop
complexity one of the problems being
older platform is there were a bit like
a show like Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones if you started watching Game of
Thrones at the beginning of season five
with no other knowledge about Game of
Thrones you'd find it quite confusing
and hard to follow if you pick up
basically the dotnet framework today and
look at basically the VCL it's quite
hard to follow if you're a newbie right
I've got an EB on my team and I had to
explain to her what WCF was for the
other day right we never use WCF
anywhere publishing some of our older
code you know she looks at things and
said what is this dotnet remoting
librarian should I said should I
understand that and it's kind of like no
no just just leave that alone right and
that's a problem this big surface area
that's there is essentially a barrier to
entry so if I go and look at a new
language one of the attractions of new
language like guises there's not much
surface area you know that's a problem -
you're right but there's not many lives
I feel like I could understand that
language and I could grow with it so
unless essentially you have a kind of
Year Zero and reset to say well these
are the essentials we can push the older
stuff aside it can be quite intimidating
okay Visual Studio is a fantastic IDE is
multi-threading support is just
absolutely brilliant and you can be
normally productive in it but there's a
challenge to getting people to learn
Visual Studio and learn essentially your
language and framework at the same time
it's a barrier to new entry yeah the way
people want to learn our language is
download your language in your runtime
and get you know their favorite text
editor from notepad or vim or sublime or
even code right and actually write some
simple programs and build up complexity
they don't want quite often the
beginning when you're beginning to learn
your language you don't want to have to
learn you know the debugging tool you're
just going to relate some statements to
print stuff out and see what happens and
the problem is the visual studio and
dotnet have historically been quite
coupled to each other to the extent that
it you know we often find there are
decisions being made about a language or
run time because of Visual Studio and we
need to kind of wean the community off
Visual Studio lovely as it is
as the kind of entry point we need to be
assured that scenario of I damaged the
language and around time I just work in
in notepad or whatever works for us
community yes they leaving dotnet emails
there are many of them actually if you
go and search for any language you can
find leaving emails I did this a combo I
think I think was like when go came out
I found leaving go email is this is like
two years ago I'm sure there are leaving
be emails even now right the people
basically throwing a strop saying be has
jumped the shark I can no longer work in
it every language has these and per se
they are not a problem right you should
expect people to move on from the
platform but the question is whether
they are indicative of a bigger problem
I think these kind of emails are
problematic right love Rob for calling
enterprise developers derpy in this
whole attitude that c-sharp developers
are somehow lesser because they work
Enterprise you know actually enterprise
developers are I have been one in my
time they solve similar problems
everybody else their focus is a little
different because the business keeps
turning there a cost and they need to
basically reduce cost as much as
possible etc and not the core business
often but they have a different set of
demands which is essentially pragmatism
productivity and not to service using
the new thing because it's trendy but
actually solving real problems but it
does I think hint both those things that
are danger for us and that's the danger
that essentially you know a lot of
dotnet meetups denial to most of the
others I deal in the keynote what we're
getting a bit old and white and male and
that's potentially a problem right it's
a problem but allowing in terms of
diversity but in terms of new entrants
and in terms of it being an echo chamber
and there is genuinely a need for us to
attract new people onto our platform
right who will essentially give us new
energy and give us new insights and new
inspirations and we need to avoid a
monoculture not necessary in
monoculture but a community monoculture
where effectively we don't say we want
to hear new voices we want to hear new
opinions you want to be challenged the
orthodoxy should be overturned right and
you know people like me are danger right
you come to NBC and you see me every
year right and that's a danger right
because what I could be completely wrong
there probably am and we need newer
younger voices coming up here and taking
my spot and saying I have great ideas
okay Hara Wilson said the expert is
prime minister you know the only place
that you could that you can't admit
change should be the cemetery we as a to
be a living platform we constantly have
to effectively engage with disruption
okay so how the languages succeed right
had a things basically Howard net core
succeed most of you probably seen this
is the hype cycle and this talks
essentially about the journey anything
goes through before towards mainstream
so this is idea effectively the hype
builds our third one gets very excited
about there's nothing fifth language can
do you know it's going to create peace
in the Middle East and solve cancer
remember the Java hype cycle was quite
excessive at one point and then everyone
crashes because it turns out it can't do
all these things in fact off
disillusionment some languages die there
right and never emerge from that trough
it turns out the expectation was too
great and it doesn't really do anything
but if they survive what happens is
those enterprise developers the
pragmatist the people trying to solve
problems for their employers say this
can actually do things for us that help
and they begin to adopt it so chocolaty
solutions about 5% of people and then
effectively you get more I would
guesstimate that's where a lot of our
languages which we care about are today
are an upcycled I made this up it could
be quite wrong but essentially you're
the mature languages C plus CC shop job
you're going to see them right over
towards the right you're going to see
the emergent players who are climbing in
terms of numbers node Python etc further
down and then essentially you're into
this kind of like the other side of the
trough don't net core I think it's
probably past the top of its hype cycle
because we're now in the trough of
disillusionment about dotnet standard
project Jason this is natural or Lange
just go through this period right don't
it's not a bad sign it's just all of us
going but it doesn't really is it's not
magic well I did it not magic
I don't have to work swift swift and go
obviously doing very well
etc right Courtland I suspect property
is a top of its hype cycle with recent
announcements and then not people new
people come to clean and they will start
complaining right don't make or numbers
in the UK about that it's a very weird
number a miniature the guest number
based on things that actually specially
say I want to hide on that core
developers that's kind of what you'd
expect at this point I think in a cycle
this is this is the thing that the key
that this thing called crossing the
chasm so this idea effectively that
you're early adopters and innovators you
pick up nearly anything that comes along
down the line right there the guys that
every NBC you're sitting talking about a
new technology you know this its Elm
this year now I've abandoned my old
rails ways I'm into Phoenix and Alexia
now right and then you get the normal
people effectively the normal Enterprise
devs who essentially are in the early
majority the people who say well hang on
a minute once things actually have
proved themselves a little bit maybe
there's a solution that we're in here
that we can use consultancies make a lot
of money essentially being the people
that do what's called bridging the gap
where effectively they look to what all
the cool kids and the startups are all
using and they say some of this
technology has a value and we can go and
essentially going so help enterprises
transition to it so the things that the
thought works TechRadar
something's that's really about the
consultants is trying to sell you
bridging the gap these two graphs
effectively can be aligned so
essentially the trough of
disillusionment is really where
effectively you're trying to cross the
chasm
okay and I'd say you know traditional
c-sharp is over here and don't their
core is somewhere around here so how do
we cross the chasm how do we convince
people either to come back you've left
or to come to the platform essentially
for the first time and generally the
model is the the people come to use your
particular toolkit from the other side
of the chasm if they have a problem that
is being sold the the majority of
developers working in those kind of
vamps are very pragmatic they're not
going to go out and learn F sharp
unless you demonstrate to them that they
have a problem that f-sharp will solve
you know for many of them c-sharp is
good enough and they're not going to go
and say I'm suddenly going to go to all
the effort becoming a functional
programmer and doing F sharp unless they
have a problem today which you can
demonstrate to them that essentially you
are the solution so they can't get round
or the workarounds an existing language
a problematic and over time you can see
that the inflection points in technology
often relates to paradigm shifts in our
industry
so we basically go to you know windows
effectively in visual languages take off
things that was your basic emerge we go
to the web essentially and then we get
platforms like in asp.net Rails emerging
eventually mobile comes along
essentially in a whole new range of
technologies get their day in the Sun
you know big data was one of the last
ones today I think the big inflection
point we're dealing with essentially big
paradigm shift is cloud native so this
is the move to instruct as a service
move to containers the move essentially
all to you effectively no longer dealing
with infrastructure essentially renting
it or even in weather service it
disappearing from you right that is the
big next big new shift and I think
you've got that core really wants to
take off what we have to understand is
does it help people dealing with that
scenario because that's really the next
pain point right okay we run on UNIX on
that core all right I think that's
become a bit of table stakes I don't
think it's anything else I think you
have to do this now because otherwise
people are simply going to turn you away
because you're limiting now options when
it comes to deployment the funny thing
about running on UNIX is the fact that
you can do it is as important whether
you do do it it simply removes a barrier
to the adoption of your framework and
language because people say well I could
run on UNIX that's not that's not a
concern for me anymore okay schedule of
code bases I think one of the winning
things about something like c-sharp and
it will supply some content like Java or
is that they are very good when your
code increases in size or your
development team scales and you have
more developers working
because a number of the technologies
they have like static typing generics
but a link read declarative stuff where
effectively you can write you know their
cells and be declarative and I did an
emergent is that pattern matching I mean
that essentially you can begin to deal
with go-to complexity this is the point
where people writing for example in
node.js begin to break down you can see
that trend almost effectively for those
dynamic languages in the fact that
things like typescript are doing so well
right and as essentially is trying to
rewrite jars of the c-sharp eventually
the entire world will be c-sharp not
javascript in case you hadn't realized
because others will simply turn
JavaScript infancy shop but most pet for
at four and pint is another one where
essentially ido has gone away and let
you put optional typing hinting because
the difficulty essentially of scaling
large code bases i have no idea whether
that's because he's working I think
Dropbox and they've encountered that
problem there in terms of the amount of
code they have run in Python right but
so we already have those advantages
powers and concurrency right many
languages do concurrency less support
parallelism okay so no Jess gains very
well from being from concurrency and it
uses the lib of basically a library to
do what sort of reactor pattern
essentially a message with the message
pump which effectively lets it be very
performant by yielding control when
something is waiting for IO okay but
that's not a no jesting right any
language can really support that same
model and c-sharp does violating Kuwait
what's harder on those languages is they
generally have a problem called the
global interpreter lock which means
essentially they can't really do
multi-threading because the interpreter
is always effectively a bottleneck to it
and certainly in Python if you want to
do multi-threading the threading library
actually is just essentially a library
that supports basically being IO bound
because the underlying C libraries
implement it your control and if you
want to actually you have parallelism
you have to use a multi processing
library you have to fork new processes
whereas c-sharp has the TPL keypads a
fantastic library and not I don't think
often shouted about enough how good a
library that is centrally
ilysm and i once was in a java session
where some guys were discussing you know
their dream parallelism in a library and
the guy was putting up his fantasy
library requirements at the end I was
kind of like we just described a TPL all
right and we ought to make more about at
EPR how good it is rx began on our
platform right and that is everywhere
now so it's important to understand we
have a solid platform on that
performance two things most of you have
probably seen there's been a huge effort
on performance dotnet was obviously was
criticized in the past as being nowhere
near as good the Telos no no no as good
at the JVM in terms of person well it
still has a long way to catch up you
know this move towards removing excess
allocations etc a lot of the work that's
been going on it's made dotnet core very
performant the other thing we have is
unsafe do not underestimate that job the
JVM etc has no real equivalent via Java
and he talked to people like Chris
Condren or even Greg Young who've worked
on things where they need control of
memory management they write a lot of
code using unsafe write which is stuff
that I understand most people that
necessarily always need you can do some
very interesting things and in terms of
all key things we want to talk about
today all right in terms of work coming
back if you just look at some of the
benchmark numbers basically comparing
dotnet core with no Jess today you can
see we are way more performant right we
may not necessarily be beating Jade the
JVM will go today but in terms of that
big competitor we are certainly doing
very well and this is Martyn Thompson
when in mind Thompson is AB local
mechanical sympathy it's pretty much the
guy on performance on the JVM
and he is been consistently
complimentary about what he sees is the
effort going into the CLR in terms of
performance right and you know other
people noticing right people out there I
begin to notice essentially that the new
platform is very performant and if you
went to know Jess because it was had
high throughput it was very performant
that is no longer really an argument and
you do see people actually being
recaptured
to air speed on it and there's your
early target market right people who
were familiar with c-sharp have dotnet
skills and essentially people you want
to bring back onto the platform
so the reasons you've left have gone
away and actually we're better now than
what you're using today
and then once you begin to pull some of
those people back you need to then try
and go to a new market
we're multi-platform and right and don't
underestimate that for smaller shops
this can be quite important the fact
that they can essentially have
developers with you know a smaller
skillset pit or wider range of targets
and the also shouldn't forget that the
way they're actually many youngsters
encounter things like c-sharp is
actually through doing games programming
unity not through the root of you know
in business program and that's a really
powerful way to get people onto the
platform
the other thing is we know one of our
strengths is that we do have a large
town pool right a lot of capable people
and one of the other things Twitter
talked about when Twitter went from
rails to the JVM was not this
performance but essentially its ability
to hire large numbers of developers who
had experience delivering apps working
at scale okay and we are essentially a
reason to defer businesses to target got
that right experienced developers who
know what they're doing right who can
therefore effectively give you some of
that heavy lifting that you need and
c-sharp is increasingly when we hire
graduates right and we find increasingly
there are graduates you've done c-sharp
now to spend a really good effort
basically getting into the education
sector so that you can highlight people
out of the gate C for whom C shop is not
a mystery okay
what's the future look like okay so the
class resistance cloud later what is
what is cloud data tend to mean means
microservices right it means basically
what we call 12 factor apps those apps
built to run basically in containerized
or cloud environments it means a
self-service infrastructure that is
essentially cloud and container
environments it means nowadays API first
we deal with mobile we deal with
essentially the same way we do a Web API
is really what you're you expose on the
server antifragility want to wear that
today but essentially that is chaos
engineering as in Netflix so one of
micro services I'm not going to bore you
give you a long talk and micro services
but I think we can all probably agree
decomposition of a monolithic business
system and independent deployable
services
think there are lots of various schools
of thought on quite what that
decomposition is essentia that's not
it's a relevant today so this is a shop
containers is what's going to have a
look it's a really nice kind of project
with promotes of some guys trying to
basically get provide an example of how
you would do micro services in net with
a kind of real-world example okay and
you can see essentially the idea here
that effectively we've got said web api
basically being exposed outside the data
center and we've got an event bus for
communication internally and you've got
micro services written effectively in
dotnet core right and we've also got
more traditional model where you've got
MVC app talking to basic traditional web
app I don't think that's such an
applicable story today
I love the MVC guys but I think really
you want to focus on API because you
know probably over half your traffic's
going to come from mobile so you really
need to focus on an API and building and
say your range of clients like web and
mobile are talking to that space and we
have a lot of good library is basically
to talk about in this space right so
we've got done at core obviously entity
framework Nancy we've effectively got
dapper as well as an alternative 20
framework lightweight there are tools
are talking to read a site from Stack
Exchange there's bright which I work on
doing event bus stuff on the n service
bus and mass transit if you want to
identity as well separate entities
identity service entity servers right
one of those one just known outside our
community as being a high quality
platform to doing that
this means that service staff doing that
overall end-to-end kind of service
implementation so we actually do have
quite a lot of the OSS infrastructure
you need today to build micro services
essentially and you'll see also notice
to basically that the diagram shows it
being hosted in docker
all right and you know hosting in docker
is one of those things that we're quite
good out on dotnet core and if you look
at essentially their workflow what tends
to happen with something like docker is
you know when you build you essentially
build and compile you do a restore
effectively year of your code within the
container so that means that essentially
I create a simple container just has the
runtimes quite lightweight I then
essentially share my local directory
with the container effectively I then do
a dotnet restore
and that pulls down just what I need
right and then essentially I do a bill
or attention to publish and publish
effectively and the advantage of that
build model is that I can be sure
managing my dependency chain I don't
have these kind of globalized dependency
issues so it's very powerful effectively
for working with docker API first right
the modern model is basically but
alright we focus on the API as the point
what's really interesting here is that
you get this idea effectively quarter
from the API gateways so rather than
exposing my micro service directly out
to my customers because then I couple my
micro services I quite often have this
intermediary called an API gateway right
he talked to the API gateways kind of
anti-corruption layer and that means I
can vary by my back-end micro services
without necessarily breaking any of my
existing clients I can also find that I
can avoid chatty calls because sometimes
actually to service the request from the
client I may need to make three or four
calls but in the backend and it's much
easier in terms of latency to make that
call from with inside my server
environment they can you call across
composing there and then returning the
compose result back out and we're today
you get guys basically in the client
making four or five calls and combined
the results under this kind of model you
just shift that code up to the server
but what tends to that tends to mean is
that they think would have back-end for
front-end BFS is what seven even calls
them which basically write the part this
idea of an API gateway that effectively
call your micro services on behalf of
the client there quite often written in
the same language as the client because
they're what offer an author by the
client developer but other making the
calls locally the client was just making
them on the server to reduce latency and
I would argue therefore your God wasn't
going to find even in this environment
that that's actually going to be
something like nodejs right you
shouldn't necessarily try and target
only in that space let them know Jess
guys have that right your micro services
in c-sharp target that initially as
being the sweet spot for where we have
lots of advantages in terms of managing
code bases in terms of performance over
that now admittedly if what you're
talking to is a crime is desktop or
mobile or retina xamarin yeah absolutely
you want to basically be able to write
the BFF in like a speed net
call because those guys their language
is C sharp and they want to basically
hop onto the server and write C sharp
right the other thing to be aware of of
course is that because we're micro
services platform we can write those
service in multiple different languages
so be prepared for a future in which you
are polyglot right because you may want
to use Python for data and right now you
know how do we talk about people now in
Python JavaScript and C sharp right and
that's not necessarily an unreasonable
expectation so if today what your dream
is as a server developer I'm just going
to be C Java everywhere that's probably
not a dream to hold on to in low poverty
play gateways are effectively perimeter
concerns things like rate limiting HT
estimation seat cores IP restriction
education APM there are a couple of ways
of doing this one is essentially that
you just get something like open resti
built on top of nginx use might come to
that if you want to bundle Lua scripts
essentially you do all of it effectively
in your reverse proxy the other option
effectively is to build that in 320 your
libraries there are pros and cons to
each approach putting into all of your
basically microservices effectively
means there to be very concerned with
things that aren't necessarily what the
microsoft's had to deliver but if you
don't want to have to go to building an
api gateway my probably a bit much for
you at the beginning it can be handy to
have that option of starting out by
putting those concerns into your micro
service and later on building out an api
gateway because there can be expensive
mostly you don't care too much about
this particular story apart for the fact
you need to support it so in cloud
native essentially they were moving away
from its kind of DevOps e model it turns
out what happened as i can tell is that
the developers got involved in
operations when devops came along
developers says wow there's a lot of
work here guys that you're all doing by
hand really we should just automate this
out of existence because we're all
pretty lazy developer tend to be lazy
right and so good developers anyway and
so they said well it'll focus whole
thing on existence so over time what's
happens we've moved to declarative
models like docker compose files and
really we're approaching this point
where as developers we just want to say
I want to have a RabbitMQ box
redick's box - worker boxes three web
boxes I can put that into a file and I
will just simply let the instructure
provide that fire and you know things
like as your AWS have these kind of do
that for you right I just give you
container definitions you spin up the
boxes for me the problem goes away and
servlet is kind of if you like the
ultimate point in that journey right
where we essentially say actually you
care so little about what is hosting the
CLR but essentially I can highlight it
from at a certain port once you start
getting through the containers from
service you actually stop worrying what
the underlying operating system is
because you just don't really deal with
it you deal with the runtime okay and so
that's the crystal thing about docker
that's the growth of things essentially
like a just service fabric right that
platform is a service environment
interesting must have come out the plant
the pads first on as you kind of went
too early but the growth effectiveness
of platform as a service environment
switch handle all that hosting concern
for you
because they're things like basically as
your functions and basically AWS lambda
where essentially again I don't care
about the container environment I'm
running on right so don't net core is
responsible for you being able to run in
AWS lambda right just across platform so
it's no longer caring it definitely not
being prevented from you doing there
it's put on from Google as well as in
there join New York onwards then there
you go care functions from John and
Google are you to effect to apps to put
to apps again right I don't talk on this
you can pretty find it on a line thing
ago quite easily about quite what they
are but twelve factor apps are really a
set of guidelines you should follow for
building your apps basically to run
cloud natively and what I don't want to
run through what those properties are as
I say just search for me and you can
find me talking about it videos online
but what I wanted to call out is that we
actually have quite good support in
dotnet core for some of these scenarios
right the way that dotnet cause complete
command infrastructure has been
engineered supports his model quite well
so for example you want to basically say
I won you will only want the runtime I
language installed I want a file that
says where are all my basically
dependences I want better restore them
so basically you know you can do that
from your CH project file Vaughn you get
still config in the environment right so
basically we're trying to move away from
the model of jerking templates that
essentially insert the variables and
adding configs across the board by some
curious build process it's basically
mostly templating and actually say well
things that vary by environment can live
in environment variables or in a
configuration server and you'll note
that the new configuration model within
dotnet core supports things like
basically putting them in environment
variables as a progression which lets
you essentially say well it may be in
web confi but it may have overridden
that with an environment variable on the
given environment we basically want to
have this separation of these individual
phases to allow us to more clearly
automate the process and we do have that
within dotnet we want to basically have
self-hosted services that basically bind
the ports and under dock that call
you've got things like kestrel you now
remember a self-hosted lee it's very
difficult if you want to basically run
in a docker container to put is which is
an application container inside every
docker container right you don't want to
do that so essentially your your model
as much that you want these micro
services to be self hosted expose a port
and then use something else as robust
proxy like nginx so you can use on a
server bus box if you were just you know
feeling difficult yourself and it also
talks about essentially saying you
should all of your admin code the code
codes essentially lets you do things to
maintain look after your app should
actually be shipped with your
application and you know the CLI stuff
around on there is really powerful
tooling for us to essentially automate
basically those processes okay so I'm
going to give you a little bit of a
model of kind of how I see the future
right so now if you notice I'm on Ward
Lee's model which talks about there
being pioneer setting Tampax pioneers
are the guide to go and build the MVP we
don't know what the customer wants going
to try something set those are the
people that say oh my god it took off at
scale it and town planners people saying
everything is kind of like mature let's
maintain it I would suggest that we are
still in probably in a world where we
let those guys target basically early
versions and we really want to target C
sharp strength as being when you come in
as a settlers and town planners saying
that was a great idea let us take over
so you know you're trying to kill no
juice out of the environment whatsoever
at all we are trying to say essentially
we can coexist because there are things
you do badly and we can help with and
you know you're likely to find that
you're going to enter an environment
where there's been a model to threaten
in nodejs or Ruby or Django and Python
and what you're trying to do is then
break the composer into basically
micro-services written c-sharp I don't
think necessarily you want at this point
to try tackling being the people
building the micro-service again oh and
you can basically other things quick
shopping list
I'm guessing it's pretty fast there are
a number of things out there we we might
want to think about building and there's
a plenty of opportunity essentially
within the dotnet open-source space
people to make their mark these are all
the kind of things that you need to have
in order to build a rich micro service
infrastructure and we can use tools
built other languages in some of these
cases but it would be useful to have
some of these particular ones I want to
call out are things like templates and
wizards basically for micro service
environment so setting up basically the
basic template for I want to use these
particular pieces of kit can you
basically set me up the basic project
infrastructure 11 so coming to drop
wizard configuration servers you could
use things like console and vault but it
might be interesting to actually sit
figure out whether we could do something
useful effectively in dotnet around
those and supervisor workers you know we
could use supervise in order to get this
done but maybe we want to basically have
something that works cross-platform
you know top shelf Windows services
they're not cross-platform so what's our
future going to be which is we're just
going to use supervise we're going to do
something else okay
community is what I want to catch this
one quite fast about minutes right so if
we are resetting the community around
dotnet core I think we want to basically
make a few changes as we go through the
thing is write any community needs to
constantly reinvent itself because all
communities alike leaky buckets people
leave and eventually the bucket we run
dry and and we have a big bucket in
c-sharp there are lots of men and
millions of developers but but
eventually we will run dry
you commonly plug these holes people
will always leave so you have to refill
the bucket and if we don't refill the
bucket the danger is essentially we
become an echo chamber right the same
people attacking the same ideas with no
new inspiration and even worse what
happens is some of these people
essentially provide a barrier to
interest of new entrants because what
they say is there now we have
established people we are the authority
we say how you do stuff right you can't
get in you haven't paid your dues my god
you don't even know what WCF is there's
no way you could contribute towards our
community right and we have to really
break down that barrier to encouraging
and welcoming new entrants to giving
their chance to make the mark I have a
personal thing is we need to get out of
slack right stack is not public it's not
discoverable you need to be a need to be
having the conversation places that are
accessible developers look like this in
case you didn't know right not like this
room sadly we need to be we need to have
a community that basically looks like
this I would call out the Python
community who are always very
self-effacing about their efforts but I
believe that one of the reasons Python
has grown is as it has it has
prioritized the diversity of its
community is being important too and it
welcomes developers of all ranges
including hobbyists there are a wide
range of c-sharp developers and one of
the things we often get accused always
being dirty right but actually know what
we should embrace the badge of being a
wide-ranging in terms of interesting
ability levels and not be elitist
because elitist puts people off and
drives them away from our community
right which someone's talked about
rewriting all dotnet it's divisive in
the US as a moniker but what we care
about is the fact that in the Europe
particularly all dotnet became a moniker
for people holding meetups etc or
whether it's participation rather than
basically someone or lecturing to you
and the reason we want to bring that
back is that feel you can go to a
meet-up where essentially you are
sharing with peers not simply being a
lecture that okay because ultimately if
we are going to have any kind of
Renaissance it is not going to be me
that essentially creates it on my own
right and hopefully the guys and the
asp.net team they're lovely guys but
there are only so many
and they can't do it all the people that
will create a donut Renaissance edu you
have to do it if you want this to happen
you have to participate right and you
have to bring others into participation
in the community we can do it but we can
do it right not I can do it not
Microsoft can do it you have to be there
we need some people to come forward it's
kind of like to be heroes right for our
community at this point in time and
actually say we want change right we
want basically a better community than
we had yesterday and I think that's very
doable I think you know I have been
consumed continually inspired a period
of time in my history by a community
we've done some very powerful things
together I think energy levels are a bit
a bit um a bit low and I think the now
is a time for us to sign of kind of step
up and say let's talk about how we make
our community more diverse let's talk
about how we get new entrants let's talk
about how we become the commute is known
to being very very open okay that's me
thanks very much please don't forget to
vote and please do like comment on
Twitter I'd love to see a conversation
about how we do this I do not have all
the answers and you guys certainly may
have very good answers you should share
thanks rash